hello hearties all over the world
thank you so much for joining us for yet
another special
live event celebrating season eight of
hallmark channels when
calls the heart you guys know me i'm
deidre behar with entertainment tonight
and today i'm joined by some of my
favorite gentlemen from home valley so
help me say hello to aaron buckles
paul green and viv lee [ __ ] hi guys
hi everybody how are you i love these
smiles so much
plaster smile hi
hi everybody it's good to see you it's
been so long
it's started it's so nice to see your
faces
of course we're celebrating season eight
of when calls the heart which has been
on fire this season and i'm going to get
into some questions
but first you know i want of course i
want to acknowledge that we are still at
home
um how has life been for you guys viv
you're the new
guy in town so i want to start with you
what is life like at home for you right
now
well um father of three husband
so i just listen to what everybody tells
me to do that's all i'm doing
you know making breakfast and lunches
and
picking kids up and that's that's what i
do literally
every day going on picking people up
taking them to
track practice or you know whatever they
have to do whatever they want to do
that's what i do total super dad
i just keep up with my wife that's what
i'm trying to do that's all i've been
trying to do
have you and your wife been able to tap
into any hobbies or or relax or do
anything that you guys like love doing
around the house
actually my wife has decided that she
wants to take up woodworking
and uh she's yeah she's currently taking
a woodworking class it's really cool
and uh she's already got plans for
redesigning the whole house like she's
she's already
she's got plans for the basement that's
what's going on right now
wow well that is seriously impressive i
have got to up my quarantine game i have
not
channeled my inner woodworker quite yet
so we're going to call her
now's the time do it do it now do
everything you want to do
totally uh aaron buckles great to see
you how are you i'm so good i've been
actually doing a lot of the same i
actually i live with my sister
we're roommates and uh we've been doing
like some renovations in the house
we redid our deck so we put a bunch of
sod down
like fake grass but it's like got a
little like palm springs
vibe out there it's pretty sweet and
then we got a breakfast sniff we just
built i'm sitting in it right
now so super excited about that
wow you you guys just really know how to
stay busy and and
stay on top of your game paul pressure's
on what have you been up to
funny funny enough we actually laid
grass on top of our roof deck just like
it's like
you know it's not real grass but it
looks really real it's got holes for the
rain and
and kind of built in oasis like right
above that's
that we can be outside quite a bit and
that that just re like building the roof
deck is what we're up to and i've been
in this studio doing podcasts and
writing
uh and releasing new music and it's just
kind of been like a
a studio uh a man cave of
uh songwriting and i do a lot of live on
uh facebook and instagram and youtube so
i've been uh
on on virtual stage quite a bit quite a
bit
yeah well i know you the creativity is
just always overflowing and
we're grateful that you share so much of
that with us through social media
um of course one calls the heart season
you guys have been delivering there's
only been two episodes so far but
we are so enthralled with everything
going on in hope valley
um viv i want to kick it back to you of
course as the newcomer
to hope valley i would love to know what
has your experience been like
joining the show here in season eight um
it's been great it's been great
everybody
was so welcoming and i mean i know a lot
of the cast from
other projects we worked on like paul
and i go way back and um
martin and i were neighbors
yeah and our kids went to the same
school like we a lot of vancouver actors
know each other so
it's really cool uh and then i met my
man aaron
on here one and such a sweetheart just
like
all good welcomed me in and was just
like yeah we're gonna have a lot of fun
and you know everything's cool and my
kids
my kids getting to to work on such a
well-oiled machine and be a part of such
a
uh welcoming and warm cast is like the
greatest thing in the world
yeah it's been great yeah your son's
doing it your son's doing a good job too
man
like it's so fun to watch you watch him
do things and it's like you're he's he's
doing amazing for
uh and it's just so cool that you guys
can be there together i was so jealous
because i wasn't able
like happy for you and also being really
missing my son watching you work with
your son
yeah thanks thank you man no it's been
uh
it's been such a cool thing and my kids
they love
everybody in the cast and they'll you
know and they're just like oh they want
to go watch they want to go watch people
like when they're not even doing
anything they want to go see
what everybody's doing and uh i just
been blown away they dropped into it
and i'm really blown away by by
just just how naturally they picked it
up and that's your son's first role
right
first time yeah
yeah my my daughter's done uh voice
voice acting in the past but hadn't done
any like
film acting and so again i'm just like
it adds your element of nerves to the
whole yeah
yeah yeah you don't have to remember you
have to remember their lines
and your lines
wearing two hats two hats at the same
time
so yeah in case in case anybody missed
that viv
is playing joseph canfield this season
on one calls the heart
and your children in real life your
daughter vienna and your son elias they
are playing your kids
on the show so you kind of touched on it
there but i'm always so curious when
actors get to work
on screen opposite their kids
what is it like in those moments where
you're exchanging lines and your repair
is a proud
dad you know so proud of your kids but
you're also having to work with them as
seen partners how are you balancing that
yeah it's uh it's the biggest balancing
act i've ever had to do on set because
usually you know like i said before my
daily routine like i explained is like
you know i'm like
packing breakfast and lunches and
running up you know driving people all
over the place
so when i go to set people will be like
oh so sorry we have
four extra pages of dialogue for you to
memorize i'm like that's fine this is my
happy place it's
totally what you give me whatever you
want so
all sudden my happy place
is but now i have to be dad
and actor at the same time and
that was hard that was a that was an
adjustment
because like paul said not only am i
trying to remember my lines
i'm trying to remember their lines and
make sure that they're doing everything
right
it was a big learning curve thankfully
they uh they they like i said they fell
into it and know what they're doing but
yeah it was i had to decide between
dad and actor on elias's first day
because he got yeah peter deluise was
directing that episode
and he decided to give elias an extra
paragraph to say when he didn't know he
was gonna
have to say it and he actually got he
got so freaked out he didn't show
anybody
everybody was smiling and everything and
they took me aside and he's like
i want to go home he was so scared and i
was like
huh okay i gotta decide am i
gonna do the old school hollywood dad
you gotta do it or am i gonna be like
myself and decide
i'll have to try to get him through it
thankfully
uh we i talked him down and he was he
was
totally calm and i just i showed him
that he was really good at memorizing
stuff and we went over it in about five
minutes
he had memorized everything peter had
asked him to say
and he went up there and nailed it he
went up to the
front of the class and he nailed it and
so everybody was i said
you see that's your first day then the
everything from here on in is going to
be great you can be fine
it'll all fall into place is there one
moment that really stands out where you
had a real
proud dad moment and obviously no
spoilers but
i have to imagine there's some scenes
that your kids truly impressed you
yeah uh there's a scene coming up
in episode four where
i'm not acting i'm i'm watching my
daughter do something watching
vienna play angela doing something and
no acting i had to actually i actually
had
i had to actually think wait this is
1918.
yeah i wouldn't cry that's right i
have to tell myself don't cry don't cry
just stay strong
and and uh yeah it was hard it was hard
it was
real no acting required here you guys
i think i know what scene you're talking
about yeah you were there you were there
i couldn't hold it together i was here
enough
i was looking to him for support like
wow well that sounds really powerful you
know we'll be tuning in
episode three four all the way through
to episode 12 when we get the big finale
um my last question to you viv you know
joseph
joseph canfield is the the new guy in
town
what can you tease is going to be
included in his
journey you know what are you most
excited for fans to learn about him and
what he and his family bring to hope
valley
yeah joseph is um
he's you know i and i get it from being
a dad and being a husband
first and foremost for me
my family's safety and happiness is
is paramount you know
given that they were moving from one
place to another
and didn't really there was no you know
some people usually will move to a place
where they maybe they know
somebody but they were really coming
into a town they didn't know anybody
and it was really it's really joseph's
kind of
you know he he he met some really nice
people when he was there and really
got a sense that this is a special place
this is a this is a little different
than
what we're used to and so it's coming in
with a little bit of wariness just
because of
past um situations that the family had
been through
and but coming in with a lot of optimism
and
a lot of hope you know you know you know
we're moving to
so yeah it really is that it's
that's really the arc in the
in the beginning of the season for
joseph it is
you know we're going to make this move
and hopefully
it's the right move but he feels that it
is given how lovely everybody was
when he came through before so
yeah it's really it's it again as a
husband and a father
no acting required it's exactly what i
would do it's exactly how i feel
given the same circumstance so well that
sounds like the best acting gig ever
where you get to show up and let your
like true inner self just kind of shine
through
it really is it really is i uh i
just get to drop in and like i said it's
such a well-oiled machine
and so in essence it really is
i'm the new guy coming into the
established
you know set of characters and actors
like it really is that thing it
is you know art imitates life so
i didn't again i didn't have to act i
was getting to know some folks
yeah but i did know some folks and you
know and we and we all
had we just had a lot of fun and and
paul is very entertaining with his
guitar that's all
oh paul i got some questions about that
uh but first i i would like to ask i'd
like to ask aaron a little bit about
jessie and clara um of course
last season we got to see the beautiful
classy wedding
and now in season eight we're really
kind of diving into what newlywed
life looks like for clara and jessie so
aaron
what is what is going on with this
couple in season eight and what can you
tease
that we're gonna see well not as uh
sunny as we thought it'd be huh
no rainbows and sunshine right off the
bat yeah i think uh
coming into the season uh eva and i
especially
we thought that you know coming off of
last season
the couple just got married and they had
a few troubles kind of moving in
together
uh and getting used to living in the
same quarters
so we just assumed oh we'll come to the
seasons it's gonna be oh it's gotta be
hunky dory it's gonna be great
and then right away off the bat we're
fighting and we're like i i'll admit it
first i was like
really like would they be already at it
like past that honeymoon phase but
you were surprised that the script took
this turn oh yeah we thought we were
gonna have a lot more of like that kind
of lovey-dovey phase honeymoon stuff
going on and right away we just got
like literally our first day on set was
us doing that bedroom scene
where we're just like we're like okay
let's do it
um but like once we kind of got more
scripts and
even just hearing from other people uh
about
you know their experiences and i think a
lot of people can relate to that like
when you kind of
pass that honeymoon phase it's quite
normal to just kind of
those things that you used to love and
you you'd find like little
idiosyncrasies that would be cute
now they're just annoying if you've got
to like
you don't ever say they're annoying
that's a bad idea no i know
that's true but they become the thing
that you got to like kind of work
through together
yeah they're not annoying don't say
annoying
and i think you i think you do a great
job in the show of really showing that
even
though you know marriage has you know
these ups and down moments
you know you ultimately end at the end
of the day you really love and
appreciate your partner and and it's
been
it's been wonderful to see claire and
jesse get back to that place
absolutely and i think you know kevin
like lee has some
sage advice at the end of the first
episode that was such a beautiful scene
and it's so true it's like you
you like it's not just an emotion it's
not just a feeling
love you have to like choose to work at
it
every day and choose love and that's
such a beautiful scene they
wrote that so well seriously yeah that
was very very poignant
at the moment with the flowers in the
field it was just so beautiful
yeah and even just for jessie too i
think it was something i had to talk to
john tinker about and just like kind of
really get behind the idea of like why
would jesse be
because we'll see it as as the uh season
goes on he kind of acts out a little
more
and it makes sense from where he came
from because he's had such a chaotic
life of
living a bad boy life and you know in
the streets and stuff and
having to find his own way and now that
he's past that honeymoon phase and the
excitement's kind of gone and they're
there it's stagnant and they're he's
like okay i gotta do something i gotta
do something and he kind of just starts
to act out again so
i think we'll see a lot more growth out
of jesse and
yeah some cool stuff well aaron now you
have me stressed out when you say
jessie's gonna be acting out this season
what exactly do you mean by that what's
he gonna be getting into
just just kind of it makes sense that he
would kind of regress a bit
like some of the things that he thought
he might have
you know completely fixed you don't
really see that it's
there's still some things that he has to
work through and i think it kind of
makes sense that he would regress back
to that old version of himself a little
bit
um and he yeah it kind of takes i think
what he has for granted and
we'll see him work through that and and
how does clara deal with all of this
i don't know if i should say not so good
but
our love is so strong and i think that's
just something that we'll see eventually
is that we're
we are we're inseparable like we're
we'll stand the test of time and people
are going to see that
okay uh no pressure here i believe
every couple has their own journey at
their own pace which they feel
comfortable
but you have to ask do you think jesse
and clara
are going to be thinking about expanding
their family or starting a family
there are some discussions
i'm not going to give any spoilers but
yeah i think i could see that in our
future for sure
as as aaron completely removed from the
situation
do you want to see jessie and clara
become parents
i think so i think they're really fun
having another baby on set or just even
toddlers i think that'd be a lot of fun
right i imagine with kids the more the
merrier they're just all so joyful
i know viv's kids certainly i'm sure
brought that element to the set this
season
totally i think we should babysit first
though maybe baby jack for a couple
hours
all right we'll keep our fingers crossed
that things stay on the sunnier side
for clara and jesse uh paul i gotta talk
to you of course about
team infirmary uh it seems like things
are going
great for for carson and faith you tell
me what's in their future
uh it's pretty bumpy i mean i
it starts off uh she comes into town
yeah you know like a like a a very
confident
city girl with this uh cowboy and it
it it's not so i don't think it's going
so well at all like this
this it's it's uh it's a very different
she came back very different and the
scripts as you know they unfolded a
little bit
um there's there's stuff for both of
them to figure out with their
uh the dreams of what they want and
their dreams may not be
exactly aligned at all times so there's
there's definitely some
definitely more conflict than we've seen
with with those two
um with those folks
so i i i'm more referring to after they
got over the initial hurdle of
whoa nelly she comes back into town real
hot and then
paul you playing the guitar serenading
faith i'm not i'm not trying to be
cheesy it really took my breath away
because a i wasn't expecting it and b
it was such a beautiful moment between a
loving couple
uh i would love to know the backstory
on how your musical prowess got to be
thrown into the script
well you know there's so many great
musicians on when calls a heart that
it's it you're just literally a bunch of
horses just waiting to be thrown into
the race like really ev
there's so many great singers and uh
even people with full careers like you
know jack wagner's had a full career in
music
um i john tinker
showed up on a few of my lives over the
quarantine before we started filming and
then in the summer i
was doing them and so he knew i played
and sang and
and there was an opportunity that he
asked me if i wanted to play the guitar
and i was like yeah and then that
morning i wrote a verse to that song
waves of time and then i've since then
fully written the whole song and
released it on itunes and spotify
uh called waves of time but it was and
it started out about
you know carson missing faith but then
it turned out to
the way i finished the song was there
was uh
a distance between los angeles and
vancouver so this song became about my
true love who is kate austin my fiance
so the song
started out uh for my character and then
it quickly
you know there's not a it's hard to
really emotionally connect
to an imaginary like situation in the
past about a song in 1918
in a hypothetical song so i it's
that but the idea started with uh carson
and faith and then it finished uh it's
called waves of time yeah
i was thrilled to be able to to sing and
play and
what's funny is i had to go in the
studio and re-cut it
like i didn't know how to play so well
so i had to oh i don't have my guitar
here but i had to like
not have very efficient hands and even
not even sing my full so i had to like
back everything kind of back which was
which was a challenge to
play like i didn't really know how to
play yeah
and then to make it match for the time
because my finger picking style might be
a little more
current than that so this is just some
of the fun things you get to do when you
play
when you do your best to stay within a
time frame you like
like we do on the show but i was i was
thrilled
i i you know i i would love to hear uh
some of the other casts do their singing
and but
i get that it's got to make sense for
the story in that moment it kind of did
carson had a bunch of time on his hands
picked up the guitar
and uh was thinking about his love that
was a thousand miles away so
oh well it's almost like you've spoiled
us by giving us
this music because you know the fans us
as hardys we want
more is there a chance that we will see
more music
from you at some point during season
eight
i don't want to spoil it for you i i
really don't i
like i uh you know i really think that i
know there's some more
music that that i can say for sure but
uh whether it's for me or not i can't
really share now
it's uh i i really do um
it was really it was really great i love
what john's done with the scripts he's
from what i can you know what i my
perspective has really brought the whole
town
together in a lot of ways and had
everybody sort of
mixed together and there's a lot there's
a lot there's a lot to these scripts
that that it's very they're very
exciting
yeah this season has a lot of
excitement coming for the fans and a lot
of i would say surprises and
turns and it's a bit of a hold on to
your seat belt
kind of hold on for you know grab the
side of your car
your chuck wagon or whatever and hold on
uh
because this season's had some some
some turns in the road for sure
well my seatbelt is buckled and we're
ready to go on the ride with you
my last question for you paul and again
not trying to rush anybody here but
seeing you know the love between faith
and carson
do you think they're close to maybe
taking the next step maybe a proposal
well you see
that's complicated there's a secret that
carson carries
the entire year
with him that i'll share at the end of
the season but uh
let's just say it's it's it's uh
it's it's bumpy and it's
and it's like there's a lot of love and
there's a lot of
but these are two people that are
completely now
uh in a different uh career even she's a
doctor right and we're in a small town
and so so there's there's
i can't give it away you're gonna have
to wait and see but
but i have to actually stop talking
okay whenever we're ready to take that
step we will be there cheering and
supporting and and loving on them as we
always do
um this wouldn't be a true one calls the
heart interview
if i didn't ask you this question and i
know it's difficult because
let's just set the record straight i
know everybody at the end of the day is
truly
team elizabeth we want elizabeth and
baby jack to be happy
but if there was a 0.001
competitive advantage and you can just
say it as yourself you're a human you're
allowed to have an opinion
viv let's start with you if elizabeth
was your was your pal in real life
yes do you think she should end up with
nathan
or lucas hmm if i was elizabeth powell
in real life
i mean she knows the the
life the white you know the life of the
wife of a
mountain she knows that yes right she
she's she's done she's been through that
i mean they're both so handsome i don't
you know what are you gonna do
um huh
well yeah that's a tough one that's
tough
i can't decide i can't i tried i can't
decide you can't
i don't know i don't know they're both
great how are you supposed to decide
between them
i can't pick one i don't know sorry
if elizabeth comes to you and goes viv
i'm in a pickle i've got these two
incredible
men with unbelievable qualities to each
of them
right you have to choose viv i have to
choose one
you gotta do it bud oh man well
i mean i mean
you know let me say who told you
who's who's declared their feelings for
you
i that might be the way i would go who's
who's who said something i think we
already know who said something
okay you're talking about the bombshell
at the end of episode two are you
talking about that big moment with
nathan
yeah okay poured his heart out 1918
that's not easy
yeah nothing nothing's easy right
he just told her this woman i love you
oh
wow come on now yeah i was like
the whole time my job was on the floor i
was like go nathan i really love seeing
him
you know be so vulnerable and and really
work up the courage after
you know a couple seasons of being a
little more more timid so
is it fair to say viv is is team nathan
i think so he's a man of action and he
knows how to
bear his heart come on now and i mean
who look at that the man in uniform how
are you gonna say no to that
totally fair all right aaron buckles
nathan team lucas i used to be team
nathan i'll admit i was team nathan
because it's a show about a teacher with
a mountain i was like guys she's gonna
end up with another mountie
come on and then i'll see both of them
because they're both
so awesome right uh they are they're
really great guys
either way she can't go wrong now though
i think i've switched over i'm
team lucas now tell me why
he's just so warming
no he's you know what he has a really
good relationship with baby jack which i
think it's really
important to her and i think he can give
her a life
that will be different enough from uh
from jack but also like a lot of the
same qualities that she'll appreciate so
i think that excitement that lucas
brings will be really
exciting for it yeah let's go with team
good answer great answer great answer
all right paul
where does your loyalty lie i think she
should marry them both
is that possum is that possible
oh no no okay so she's
it's tough because nathan because of the
risk of the job could be
you know she could re revisit a very
tragic past
very quickly and lucas's father left
the mother and lucas is a wanderer
and you know he's also got a lot of
mystery
and so neither neither are really very
good options from what i get from what i
can tell i mean
it's she's it's a tough decision like
they're both we just went from they're
both incredible
we love them both we cannot get enough
of both and now paul is like
i don't know about either left there
hard left i know i know i know what do
you do what do you do if you're
if you're not if you know if i was her
friend and i wouldn't want her to get
hurt i would be like hey
maybe you know stay single for a little
while
and see which one kind of survives the
great wild west i don't know
honestly honestly i've gone back and
forth my mom is
is team uh nathan so i'm just gonna have
to go with my mom because
she you know i she's got
she's got a pretty good uh grasp on on
um
what's good for people is she sure
thought she knew what was good for me
growing up
well okay so paul your team nathan i
i need poker faces from you gentlemen
because i know you know how the season
ends
without revealing anything i want to
know what was your
expression what was what was running
through your mind when you
read the i assume finale episode of
season eight and
and you finally saw the resolution to
this love triangle
viv what was going through your mind
there other than giving it a thumbs up
what was going through your mind
well i was like uh-huh well i can see
why you did that that's what i was
thinking i could see why that happened
i see that okay you seem pleased with
the end result
yeah yeah and
okay aaron buckles can i see your
expression
yeah yeah i was like
that was my expression uh i was happy
for her she makes a great choice
okay how do you think how do you think
the hearties will react to it
i think at this point they just want her
to pick so i think that like
they'd be happy with either of them i
really think
that's true you think you're really hard
to be happy because you know
it's like love triangles it's fun but
it's also just a lot of turmoil for it
you know
yeah yeah let's have some you know have
some love
that's happening yeah no enjoy your life
enjoy
relax you know enjoy the companionship
paul how do you think the hearties are
going to react once elizabeth finally
makes her decision
well depends what team they're on i mean
it's it it truly just depends which side
of the fence that they're
you know they're swinging for so i'd say
half of them are going to be
thrilled and the other half are gonna
come to terms pretty quickly
about it you know they're gonna they're
gonna i think
they're gonna be gonna be very concerned
as well
well listen here's here's my personal
hot take if you love the show
if you love elizabeth you just want her
to be happy so even if the quote team
that you were rooting for
doesn't necessarily win in the end erin
cracow has already confirmed
neither gentleman is going anywhere
we're still going to get lots of
heartwarming moments with
you know the show the show's about
community it's about this group of
people and we've really fallen in love
with
everybody um um whether they're you know
the quote lucky suitor who gets picked
or
they're just someone else who moves on
and finds love and happiness in a
different way
so totally i think everybody's going to
be excited
before we wrap up do you guys have time
for a quick little rapid fire game
yeah okay let's do it so i
affectionately call this game
who's your guy the the gentleman on one
calls the heart are truly
top-notch on-screen and off-screen so
i'm gonna give you a a question or a
category and you just blurt out the
first guy that comes to mind
yeah okay is most likely to be caught
snacking at craft services
chris chris mccally chris
i say meat
do you do you see chris at craft
services quite a lot
yeah right oh yeah he's always got a cup
in his hand even when he's not
like one of those little fruit cups or
something that's like oh he's
not even in my trailer he's watching
alive and he was eating the whole time
he's very healthy but he never gets food
in his beard i must say i'm impressed by
that
i don't i don't understand i don't
understand that i have food in my beard
right now
yeah i'm just getting used to this and
i've already got it all over you know
who is most likely to pull an on-set
prank
paul kevin isaac
paul paul i feel like i've heard some
stories in the past i know
right yeah certain people i won't say
any names
uh uh aaron not this aaron
hates being scared so um aaron krakow
does not like being scared
which takes out all the fun of scaring
for me
so i would say that my sparkle
is quite diminished as a result but
you know i've scared martin coming
pretty dramatically
on this trailer and i'm always going up
to people and biting them on the ankle
like like a pretend dog it's just i
can't help myself
i really can't and i uh if somebody has
to be like paul i
hate that for me to stop otherwise it'd
be like fun right it's fun right
i've never grown up so did you know viv
is the new guy on the show did did viv
get any
was he on the receiving end of any
pranks this season viv was hurting cats
i didn't want to throw us another
spanner in the works
like you know he was he was not actual
cats but he had his children there and
it was a
there was i felt like there was quite a
bit i i don't think i scared you did i
oh you took mercy on me you did yeah you
said
that has an expiration date i know i
know so
i'll be ready okay ready i was gonna say
fingers crossed we get a season nine so
paul can can can have his moment there
well it's gonna happen
i think so uh who is most likely to
break character in the middle of a scene
i would say kevin probably kevin mcgarry
what does he get the giggles yeah he's a
goofball yeah he's a bit of a
yeah he's a bit of a goof and he can go
from
not like just talking to being super
serious like like really easily
he i from what my from my experience and
and he's
hilarious so it's but calvin's right
there too i think kevin
yeah yeah say kevin yeah and on the flip
side
who never breaks who's just always like
in hyper
mega professional mode mr webb
no you're right you're jack wagner
you're right i've never seen jack
breaking the scene
really wow no i'm keeping it aggressive
aaron has their crack oh she gets the
giggles
she can go for it too paige is a
dialogue i've seen her just
focus man yeah oh yeah for sure okay i
want all three of you to answer this
if you could pick a character on the
show to be your best friend in real life
who would you choose
ned oh elizabeth of course
aaron i'd go with hickam hiccup's a fun
time
he comes great good guy
it's good to see more of hickam this
season he's really
getting his hand yeah he's getting
involved yeah it's wonderful
yeah you topped off i mean yeah it's
doing great
meds ned's a good listener so i don't
you know we don't have to talk about our
feelings too much with ned
you he listens intently yes and my my
last question if you guys could play
a different character for a day or for
an episode
who would you want to play and why
i think rosemary oh yeah
okay it would be so crazy
it would be so fun to make everything
that big and it and it and it'd be just
in the normal like it would
she she has a really great way of making
rosemary
so bubbly without it looking at ever
like she's over acting
or ever it's it would just be really fun
to have that
much fun and i think rosemary is
constantly
just like you know yeah so i would love
to see you do that
sure can we start a position i would
absolutely love to see that
yeah it would be really fun i she's got
this the the
yeah it's her voice too her voice is so
her voice reminds me of so many people
in my family like my cousin karen
and she has a slight canadian kind of
warmth to it that reminds me of my whole
family
yeah i love that okay we're gonna we're
gonna
absolutely start a fan petition for that
paul to see you channel your inner
rosemary at some point
uh aaron buckles who would you like to
play for a day
i think i would pick bill because he's
always out investigating he's always got
some like cool
like missions like a detective so i
think it'd be fun to go out there and
solve some crime i love that
uh judge flynn i think has a nice ring
to it
right yeah you walk up that ladder
absolutely
and uh and viv who would you like to
give a shot for a day
oh nathan of course i get to wear the
red jacket come on now
that's it that's what it's all about
ride the horse the whole thing
the jacket please i think i look good in
that jacket
i really do yeah yeah you would
100 before we wrap up is there any final
message that you would like to send to
the hearties you know the show has
obviously
meant so much to so many people for
years but especially over the last year
i think the show has really provided
a sense of of normalcy and comfort to
many people around the world
is there anything that you guys would
like to say sure i just want to thank
thank say thank you to the hardys for
you know really being so well
organized and so like they're
they're the and so lovely and so
passionate about
what we're creating that you know
there's such a massive
movement and such a a big reason that we
keep to
get are allowed to keep creating stories
like this because
we have this massive audience out there
that's that's really excited about
our characters and the town and and so
i'll just a huge thank you to the hardys
uh for being there through you know
through all the ups and downs and
and now through this time that we're in
there's just the support and the love
from them has been amazing yeah ditto to
all
that you guys keep up with what they're
saying and the edits that
they make because the hardy's put a lot
of time and thought and care
into a lot of these videos and images
that i see on twitter and social media
oh yeah they're crafty they are they are
crafty
so creative yeah yeah i i gotta say i
have some some
family members that are big hearties and
you know before i got on the show i'd
say oh i'm doing this other thing and
they'd be like oh that's not nice but
now
everybody's excited calling me and they
want to get spoilers i'm like
no no i'm not telling you anything you
got to watch you got to watch that tune
in so
uh it's it's amazing to see
how welcoming the community has been
like the hardee's
it's literally like walking it's like
riding into hope valley
so welcome it's incredible i haven't
seen this
before and i mean i've been acting a
long time and i've not seen a fan base
come out like this to welcome somebody
new it's it's
incredible they are absolutely amazing
yeah it's a special place and they
they drive it you know you can feel
every you know everything
we do the hardies are wrapped up in all
of it i think yeah you can you can
definitely feel the hardee's all their
love it's like wrapped up in the show
and i think that's something that's
really cool about this season i'll just
say real quick
john tinker did a really great job of
like bringing like i think you mentioned
that earlier paul just
having all the characters kind of
intertwined and it feels more like a
like a community like that we got all
that hearty love kind of like
wrapped it's a really good season i
think they're really gonna love it
well i know gentlemen have just
scratched the surface we've got
episode three coming up this sunday i
encourage everybody to tune in
9 p.m on hallmark channel when calls the
heart of course tweet along with us
hearties and i am so excited to see what
happens next thank you gentlemen for
your
time thank you you're welcome
bye everybody